politics is service for the people for
those who elect a politician
angela merkel's a leader she's not a
follower
strong-willed
firm
she is a problem solver you know she's a
she's a manager of a situation who is
ruthlessly pursuing
what she considers to be the right path
my disagreement with her
concerns what that path is
we manage many things we'll manage this
in critical moments angela was that lady
led madame who
intervened
and helped us to find the solution what
i think has been lacking has been
strategic vision she always tried to get
everyone on board but she never really
was outspoken on what kind of
eu she wanted
i said i want to get a bit of rest and
then we'll see what comes to mind but i
will no longer be involved in politics
[Music]
we begin the day as the sun begins to
set on the era of german chancellor
angela merkel in a few days after 16
years in power and almost exactly as she
had planned angela merkel will depart
the political stage for good tonight in
a dramatic yet modest torch-lit farewell
ceremony german soldiers offered their
gratitude and highest honor to merkel
merrill then offered her thanks to the
military and the nation for allowing her
to occupy the highest seat of public
service for 16 years there was no
departure from style or substance
tonight in her speech the chancellor
called on her country and its allies to
remain true to the values that made her
life and her story possible
as i stand before you today
i feel above all gratitude and humility
that's the humility for the office that
i was allowed to hold for so long
gratitude for the trust that i have
experienced
i have always been aware that trust is
the most important asset in politics
i am convinced
that we will be able to continue to
shape the future well if we set out to
work
not with discontent
with resentment
with pessimism
but as i said three years ago in another
setting with cheerfulness in our hearts
at least this is what i've always held
on to
in my life in the former east germany
and even more so now in freedom
it is this cheerfulness of heart that i
wish for all of us
and figuratively speaking for our
country and for the future
i thank you
from the bottom of my heart
[Applause]
and joining me here at the big table
tonight for this special edition of the
day is our chief political editor
michaela kufner it's good to see you
mckellen when you look at tonight's
ceremony
was it a fitting farewell ceremony for
angela merkel
i think it very much was and i think
that in her short speech we did get what
made her chanceship so different the
level of modesty particularly in the
face of so many
male
chauvinistic leaders that she faced
throughout her time
and also with her choice of songs which
i think
gave a lot of us a completely different
insight that she was listening to kind
of funkier music than a lot of us had
predicted yeah i mean these um songs of
choice they rose
i guess they raised some eyebrows um
talk to me a little bit about that i
mean there was one what punk
yeah nina hagen she is kind of the
german queen of punk rock she also comes
from a family of um
of
well really artists and and um system
critical song writers um in the east of
germany and she the song
is it's a woman criticizing her
boyfriend that he didn't take the color
film to on their holiday to um to an in
east german island which we have to
explain to a lot of viewers would not
even know what of what color film was
when there were cameras when you
actually put the film in you're right
brent we are very old there are actually
today it's an app
exactly previously you actually needed a
film which is the color one is more
expensive and the black and white was
not an app it was it was kind of cheaper
film at some stage and um it
she said that um this wasn't really
laden with a kind of meaning because
somebody asked her today at a press
conference where i was about the song
she said it was basically a a memory of
her youth
which she of course spent in um in east
germany so and this highlights this
history of not only was she the first
woman chancellor she was also the first
east germans who really had something to
say uh and at the head of the country
and it's interesting too because just
when you least expect it angela merkel
does something like choosing a german
punk
artist song
she chooses something that gives you a
little bit of a glimpse into her
private personality yes and there must
be a diva in there somewhere as well
because the other song is was
issued rain red roses for me and then
there were red roses there for her and
it was it's a very grand song um from a
post-war diva here in germany and you
know who would have thought
and then there was a more predictable
one a church song
she she is a person
after all all right michelle stay right
there we're going to be returning to you
more analysis in just a moment we're
going to talk a little bit now about
style merkel has
not only defined a political error here
in germany for an entire generation she
is the only leader that they have known
16 years and she has become
a living icon now for almost two decades
merkel has been the woman in charge with
an unmistakable
look
a conservative pant suit and the
signature
hand gesture that everybody tries to
copy on the world stage merkel won
respect keeping her trademark calm as
she went toe-to-toe with unpredictable
leaders and there were plenty of them in
germany she was largely seen as stable
and able both germany and europe are now
losing their most experienced crisis
manager
angela merkel controlled stable giving
away nothing over the past 16 years she
created her own brand of stability
politics rooted in science and her
original definition of what it's all
about
[Music]
to me politics is service for the people
for those who elect a politician
[Music]
became germany's first woman chancellor
[Music]
so help me god
immediately she raised the alarm over
climate change as a threat to humanity
but she would fail to meet her own
climate ambitions like most of the
world's most powerful leaders she
prodded into action
soon events would demand mackel's focus
and her forte became managing crises
the collapse of lehman brothers in 2008
and the euro crisis that followed saw
mackel's stability politics survive a
baptism of fire
her word was enough to calm the nerves
of german savers
we tell all savers that their funds are
safe the government will make sure
but forcing austerity on greece and
other countries also sparked hostility
and fear
in mackel's eyes the role of the
chancery was above all to provide
stability and with each passing year
more people would take her name to mean
just that
her legacy is defined by a key event in
2015 when large groups of mostly syrian
refugees risked their lives to come to
europe mackel left the german borders
open around a million people came to
germany she insisted failure to
integrate them was not an option
we manage many things we'll manage this
while she was hailed abroad for her open
arms policy at home she was targeted by
right-wing populists who chanted
macklemore
mackel must go
[Applause]
to this day europe lacks a common asylum
policy
mackel's plan to focus on europe in her
final year was derailed by the covert 19
pandemic
a scientist herself she did not hesitate
to accept the magnitude of the threat
it is serious take it seriously
germany went into an immediate but light
lockdown mackel also crossed one of her
longest standing red lines she dropped
her resistance to eu direct debt leaving
german taxpayers standing in for other
european countries
in her exclusive legacy interview with
dw she said this was one of her toughest
moments
the two events i personally found most
challenging were for one the large
number of refugees arriving here and now
there's the kovid 19 pandemic and those
are perhaps the ones where you could see
people directly affected where people's
fates were at stake that for me was the
most challenging
mission
after 16 years as chancellor the brand
of stability politics angela merkel
created will remain a reference point
for leaders around the world
michelle that was your look there at the
highs and lows of the miracle era i mean
you've covered her for a long time what
would you say what is it about her that
makes her so special
her focus on the doable
and her
endless patience
of actually bridging positions and
bringing
about compromise one way or the other
where did she get their patients from i
have no idea
maybe it is deep rooted in her faith
that clearly is
is a big aspect she says i mean she
wishes for her a successor olaf shaw
it's the likeness of heart the joy of in
that office i actually genuinely believe
her that that she does have that joy
um and that focus amazing
yeah and she has an incredible intellect
at the same time
having said that um all of these
positive uh attributes at the same time
feed into what i would see are her
biggest faults which is that she
identifies challenges
like digitization like the climate
challenge that she identified and then
focuses completely on what is doable
and in a way it's the exact opposite of
like an emmanuel macau who has this
vision communicates it
and then starts worrying about how he's
going to get there maca will always have
built the road
to where she to get where she wants to
get if she knows she can't get there she
will redefine the goal yeah don't
inspire me
show me how to get to inspiration yeah
that's a very good point which events
would you say stick out most for you
during these last 16 years i mean which
events have defined the angular
angelamerical era
well they are um absolutely 2015 because
that is the one time where she decided
alone which is very unusual for her
and then
the corona pandemic it really crashed
her
final two years in office where she
wanted to build legacy
in terms of europe in terms of being a
european leader and particularly finding
a new joint eu stance towards and also
against china
and so that totally didn't work out and
then what is a completely non-event um
all the events she managed to prevent
she didn't manage to prevent brexit but
she did hold the shop together within
the eu whoever you ask will tell you
that
so that really is something it's not
spectacular but in some it really is
because that was not a given it just
feels like it right now
we can't stand by we're going to come
back to you in just a moment now we want
to talk about shoulders
miracle has
rubbed shoulders with some of the most
powerful and influential people in the
world during her 16 years on the world
stage one of her most memorable moments
was when those same shoulders got an
unexpected and unannounced massage from
former u.s president george w bush oh we
remember that don't we he spoke to dw's
enos pole about that famous
tactile moment
i wouldn't call it a
an extended massage i'd call it a
yeah i mean she was yeah it's kind of
a spontaneous uh
uh reflection of friendship
and i'm sure people you know
didn't know what to make of it but it's
i didn't mind it i thought it was kind
of
i thought it said wow
and uh
it's kind of i don't know yeah i mean
it's been one of those things that just
happened it certainly wasn't scripted
thank you
no back rubs
they have former president george w bush
there looking back on his impromptu
neck or back rub that rubbed the german
chancellor somewhat the wrong way here's
how he and others will remember angela
merkel
uncle merkel is a leader she's not a
follower i look at her as a sympathetic
figure
as
a decent human being
who is ruthlessly pursuing what she
considers to be the right path
my disagreement with her
concerns what that part is
[Music]
i would describe her as pragmatic and
reasonable
not bad
[Music]
she's a very strong and determined woman
but she uses that strength to inspire
not to intimidate so she brings people
together rather than
putting them against one another she is
a problem solver you know she's a she's
a manager of a situation
her ability to share the plain truth
with her own people is an immense
political achievement
[Music]
she's quite transparent
she's respectful and demands to be
respected
strong-willed
firm
decisive
[Music]
nobody could die angela merkel's
political competence her political skill
her tactical brilliance
what i think has been lacking has been
strategic vision this had to see i
appreciate her as something of a mosaic
because there's many parts to her
[Music]
so mikhail out of all of the politicians
and leaders that angela merkel has
worked with these 16 years who would you
say she really got along with the most
well she got along really well with
jean-claude juncker we just saw you yeah
she got along with barack obama very
well that was a friendship in the end
although it didn't start out
she didn't want him to appear in front
of the brandenburg gate before he
actually became u.s president yeah
imagine that so you know that didn't
work out so well yeah um
and
who else would i single out
she actually uh just you know not that
they have such a close friendship but
she interestingly in very difficult
times got along very well with theresa
may
and that was during brexit the british
prime minister during times of brexit
they really respected each other they
were at completely different ends of the
the argument they even had a giggle
together because they both wore the same
color when they were addressing their
parliaments uh one day and then appeared
in a photograph together so um she
didn't have many um other female leaders
to commiserate with
yes that's true but you know she never
really was someone who believed in kind
of a girls club kind of scenario she she
forgot in one instance that she had in
fact been the first woman
to lead her own cdu party when
introducing her successor in that up and
coming in that role and they both had
almost a giggling fit
to correct themselves so she will look
at someone she will look at what they
what their idea is what do they know
um how do they act as a human being
being i think she's post-feminist in
that sense she doesn't really think
about gender so much stand by we're
going to come right back to you we want
to look to the future now merkel
is keeping tight-lipped about what her
plans might be post-politics but here
are some of her options
what exactly angela merkel sees when she
looks into the future she's not saying
after 16 years at the helm she'll
finally have time to relax and pursue
her hobbies but what form will that take
in berlin there's been plenty of
speculation about merkel's plans for
life after retirement
david she'll take on honorary positions
become chairman of a foundation
somewhere
first michael should write her
autobiography 10 volumes
that would be my wish and i would
definitely read it
after they do something
remarkable like win the super bowl they
go to
disneyland she'll go hiking
she loves potatoes
as chancellor angela mackel saw many
heads of state come and go
each of them found their own path
following the end of their active
political careers some stayed in
politics
others simply stayed in the headlines
mackel's predecessor gerhard schroeder
decided to take up a new profession as
lobbyist for the russian oil giant gas
prom
the socialist antonio guterres served as
prime minister of portugal then went
international today he's secretary
general of the united nations
former u.s president barack obama
travels around the globe holds lectures
and writes memoirs
narco most likely won't take up the pen
or hit the keyboard former chancellors
are required by law to maintain silence
on state matters
she's not letting on what she'll do
instead
i've said i want to get a bit of rest
and then we'll see what comes to mind
but i will no longer be involved in
politics
but no one can really imagine that
angela merkel will refrain from taking
on any official position whatsoever
not least because as former head of
government she's going to be very well
equipped for other work
as chancellor angela merkel earned a
salary of 25 000 euros a month
three months after she leaves office
that sum will drop to 15 000.
she'll be entitled to security
protection and an official car with
driver until the end of her life
as well as an office in the bundestag
including an office administrator and
three staff members
angela merkel's been using her last
weeks in office to pay farewell visits
at home and abroad here in france
her current role may be that of a
caretaker but there is plenty to take
care of she'll be keeping political
appointments right up to her very last
day
at any rate she seems to be taking
pleasure in the prospect of soon leaving
politics behind okay
was that it yeah
yeah i mean she's definitely earned her
retirement because how do you think
she's going to be remembered
hmm
as um
an outstanding european leader
also is someone who totally didn't do it
for the money now that we saw like cash
sector
i mean really talk about no drama she
doesn't like fuss she doesn't like drama
and no expensive hobbies um she's you
know her dream is to do a bit of
gardening work i mean honestly i've been
trying for weeks to imagine her doing
gardening work some people say they
can't imagine her i'm like i can see
you're doing that um yeah
for how long
i i can see her doing like like carrots
and corn and but not like geraniums and
things like that you know what i mean
there's a difference
right yeah
thanks for pointing out so stop doing
something constructive that's what
you're talking about and she definitely
wants to sleep in and i totally believe
her believe that i think she is
genuinely physically
tired as well this has been a very
strenuous past two years
and um but we don't want to be too
compassionate towards international
leaders i think she doesn't she she
sees power as a responsibility
just power for its own sake doesn't
interest her and this is where she is
very different from a lot of
her counterparts around the world
our chief political editor michelle
koeffner michelle thank you for
walking us through the the end of the
angle of miracle era thank you
well finally we will be posing this
question for a very long time in a
male-dominated world of politics how did
she do it where did her stamina her
patients come from how did it all seem
so effortless a master of politics armed
with modesty not vanity now there is
much to criticize about angela merkel
you know she was not an architect of the
future instead she kept her finger on
the pulse of the present too much
innovation creativity
spontaneity those were not miracles
calling cards and that is why the next
government will have to dedicate energy
time and money to catch up and to make
up for lost time but merkel also never
promised those qualities either she told
the truth in fact in her 16 years as
chancellor she had no personal scandals
zero to distract from her work good luck
finding a president or a prime minister
with that record
the world will miss angela merkel let's
hope we don't end up missing the values
that made so many respect her for so
long
[Music]
we'll meet again
don't know where
don't know when
but i know
we'll meet again
some sunny days
[Music]
keep smiling through
just like you
always do
till the blue skies drive
the dark clouds
far away
and will you please say hello
to the folks that i know
tell them that i won't be long
and they'll be happy to know
that as you saw me go i was
singing this song
you